[Música]
la organización actividad de ayuda
social una fiesta para un grupo de niños
de la fundación de cuidado para la que
llegaron más de 30 niños y sus padres me
encantó poder compartir con algunos de
estos niños aunque muchos de ellos
estaban realmente en perros eran niños
felices estos niños pasan en sus hogares
por su enfermedad y esto me puso a
pensar que de seguro su vida podría ser
un poco triste o aburrida como niños
tenemos necesidad de relacionarnos con
otros niños porque para ellos las
partidas son limitadas lo que más nos
sorprendió es que muchos de estos niños
salgan que van a morir pronto y tenían
las algas en muchas cosas
de esta actividad me quedaron cositas
como juguetes comida y ropa y tomé la
decisión de hacer unos paquetitos y como
a mí ir un día salmons a repartirlos y
poder compartir con algunos de estos
niños un dato al igual que con los niños
de la fundación estos niños estaban
felices estos niños pasan largas horas
en las calles pierdo dinero para poder
comprar su comida del día y también
super que hay niños que tienen que
buscar dentro de la basura su comida del
día de camino a casa estoy conversando
de este tema con mamá me tenía realmente
sorprendida
este año viendo las noticias que estaban
hablando sobre la pobreza infantil el
entrevistado en un representante de la
unicef que comprobaban las estadísticas
de la pobreza infantil en costa rica y
comprobaba que en costa rica 427 mil
niños viendo en la pobreza cinco de cada
diez no podrán terminar sus estudios
ustedes saben esto
ya no la sabía y me sorprendí muchísimo
y pensé que costarían con estos niños
que no pueden estudiar que no pueden
pagar el bus para ir a su escuela que no
pueden comprarse cositas que no pueden
estar con sus amigos o no pueden ir al
cine
entonces pensé en todos estos datos y me
puse a reflexionar sobre esto y estaba
realmente sorprendida sobre estos datos
tanto como los niños de la fundación
estos niños también se sorprendieron por
estos niños que también tenían que
buscar dentro de la basura o tenían que
poner dinero en las calles estos niños
también tenían que sufrir mucho por las
noches o por el día por el hambre o por
el frío entonces me puse a pensar que
entonces qué pasaría con estos niños y
los adultos no nos ayudan o tampoco a
nosotros nos ayudamos
entonces con ser en todos estos datos y
empecemos cambien una solución a todos
estos niños
yo tengo casi todos años de zenani
emprendedora tomé la decisión de hallar
a niños de clase social media-baja para
que pudiesen ser niños emprendedores y
den un taller para niños de 2 a 6 años
donde les enseñe mis 5 estrategias de
negocio básicos también les enseñe a
hacer un producto de chocolate que fuese
económico práctico y que se pudiese
vender y así comenzar a hacer su propio
negocio 35 talleres en total 42 niños y
5 de ellos ya están desarrollando su
propio negocio esto demuestra que los
niños queremos y podemos ser
emprendedores
también pensé que los niños necesitamos
un espacio para demostrarle al mundo de
los adultos que nosotros podemos ser
niños emprendedores por esto me acerqué
al gran centro comercial del sur donde
me dieron la gran oportunidad de poder
organizar la primera feria de niños y
niñas emprendedores de costa rica fue el
pasado 8 y 9 de septiembre tuvimos 24
expositores de 6 a 17 años mi feria fue
totalmente inclusiva todos con la mirada
de que su negocio se convirtiera en una
empresa
todos podemos acercamientos en redes
sociales buenos ingresos económicos y
podemos compartir a los demás sobre
nuestras ideas de emprender
todos tuvimos mi taller totalmente en
éxito porque todos podemos divertirnos
lo más importante es que podemos motivar
a los demás a ser emprendedores tanto
adultos como niños
vivimos en una sociedad donde las
familias han sido fragmentadas también
tenemos mucha diversión de familias
la gran mayoría vienen en riesgo social
y están compuestas por niños que
terminan siendo los más afectados
se han puesto a pensar cuántos niños
tienen actividades extracurriculares
bueno se han puesto a pensar en cuántos
niños pueden ir al parque de diversiones
tiempo para pensar cuántos niños tan que
también se pueden dar el lujo de poder
bueno esta es una de todas la que hay de
los ejemplos de la desigualdad infantil
porque todos los niños deberíamos de
tener los mismos derechos
seguro no los tenemos bien derechos
bueno los niños de costa rica somos
desiguales no todos tenemos una
educación integral para no a todos
comemos ni siquiera los tres tiempos
niños de zonas lejanas sólo quieren una
atención médica para por otro lado
también están los niños con alguna
discapacidad física que tienen pocos
accesos de crecimiento
entonces pensé en todos estos datos y me
puse a pensar que cómo podría ayudar a
estos niños por eso está estos talleres
y estas ferias para poder apoyar a estos
niños necesitamos más apoyo en la
apertura de nuestros docentes más apoyo
en las escuelas para que puedan apoyar a
los niños que quieran ser emprendedores
para que lo puedan ser necesitamos que
apoyen a los niños para que también
puedan aprender sobre las finanzas
también necesitamos más apoyo de
apertura de todos los entes que
necesitamos que también apoyen a los
niños de toda manera para que sean
emprendedores y esto haría que la
pobreza infantil disminuye y así
podríamos apoyar a todo niño para que
sea emprendedor tanto para los niños que
están en la calle o tanto para los niños
que están en las escuelas
esta funcionaria tanto para todo el
mundo para adultos y para niños para
cualquier tipo siempre y cuando siempre
se apoyen
mi pareja totalmente un éxito porque
porque los niños en 22 días previos
lograron ponerle el nombre de su empresa
el logo y pudieron crear su producto
además para posterior de yo les decía a
las personas que querían a las personas
para ver si podían dejar a los niños que
estuvieran en estas caras
entonces tenía que decir ustedes que
prefieren que el niño venga a la feria y
que no haga su producto o que el niño
puede hacer este producto y no pueda
venir a la tarea esta es una de las de
igualdad en parte porque lugares que se
pueden dejar a los niños que puedan
estar en dos lugares en la tarea y con
su producto pero a niños que todavía no
tienen esa necesidad porque apenas están
con su negocio porque no tienen
suficiente dinero etcétera etcétera
entonces las personas no es ya bueno
entonces vamos a meter a estos niños
para que sean emprendedores para que los
adultos los jóvenes y los niños puedan
apoyarlos tanto como niños y adultos se
debe apoyar el emprendimiento el
emprendimiento es muy importante porque
todos podemos ser emprendedores y
siempre se inicia de una pequeña idea
pulserita con éxitos cupcakes cualquier
cosa si es un niño o niña quiere ser
emprendedor se puede ser emprendedor si
ustedes me apoyan siempre y cuando
ustedes tengan que decir las cosas que
se tienen que decir por ejemplo más
me puedes decir o a veces las demás
quieren sus sus cosas del otro puesto o
cosas así para motivar al niño para que
sean emprendedores
y está teniendo algunas de las ideas
para que los niños puedan ser
emprendedores deberían de apoyar a sus
niños decirles que si se puede siempre y
cuando estén a su lado y los estén
apoyando y siempre que estén con ustedes
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]